Chinese is my first language English as
my second so oftentimes I get quotes
wrong but the general theme of the quote
was due for a sauce forgiveness later or
really just go after it I'm Alice Zhang
I'm the CEO and co-founder of verge
genomics I'm 27 years old
Virge finds drugs to treat
neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's disease ALS and Parkinson's
by using genomic data most companies
right now still spend billions of
dollars just testing millions of drugs
in tons and tons of experiments just to
find one lead candidate and in most
cases those lead candidates fail in
clinical trials oh you know that verge
is we want to take the guesswork out of
drug discovery and development here's
how it works we usually look at
thousands of different data sets and we
find what are the hundreds of genes are
causing disease most companies just look
one gene at a time and a lot of times
that's why drugs fail so by looking at
hundreds of genes at a time we hope that
we can find drugs that actually can
reverse disease rather than just
treating the symptoms
[Music]
during my PhD I was looking at how do we
leverage all of this exploding genomic
and genetic data to find better
treatments for these brain diseases and
it was then that I realized how broken
drug discovery was it's still largely a
guessing game in neuroscience so I saw
this amazing opportunity to leverage
this this new wave of technology in
genomics to actually find drugs that
work in patients with these diseases
[Music]
I've probably interviewed personally a
thousand two hundred people to get to
the eight people we are now and so you
know just the vise would have had was be
patient to warn myself how difficult it
was but I think now we have an amazing
team of eight PhDs from really the
world's leading genomics labs and I
[Music]
think it's really important for
scientists to really know how to convey
their science to a mainstream audience
and to teach people and actively teach
people why their science is important
and why it matters I think if they can
do that they'd be surprised at the the
resources they can get to really make
their vision come true
[Music]